the biden administration is now
threatening states that don't implement
this woke ideology and the gender stuff
in schools they are threatening with
holding back school lunches for kids
that need it believe it or not yes it's
true we've got some video
we're prepared for what biden throws our
way
and you know yes part of it's the
inflation and the gas part of it are
intentionally destructive policies like
trying to deny
school lunch programs for states that
don't do transgender ideology
and the schools i mean give me a break
totally off his rocker to be doing that
we're fighting on that don't worry
can you imagine regardless of how you
feel about the gender ideology stuff
that you would punish kids i mean that's
what they're doing you would punish kids
through lunch
letting them be hungry because they're
not going woke with all of this stuff uh
marissa you're in cali again i keep
saying it i don't mean it yeah
defensively keep reminding me you know
what this makes me think about i used to
say the teacher unions hate their
opponents more than they love children
and that's what it comes down to
and uh you know that's why they keep
disappointing the children and the
families and yeah i see it in california
but by the way
the problem we have is this is not just
in california it's really all over the
country and if you ask yourself why a
big part of it is because most teachers
go through what i call left-wing
seminary
i have a master's in education most
people who go into trying to get a
master's in education will go through
this left-wing ceremony and uh
seminary and if they'll move to florida
or nashville or new york wherever they
go they'll take those ideas and
ideologies with them and like mentioned
like we mentioned before i mean these
ideas are immoral and these ideas are
not about really educating a child most
teachers actually are not even taught
how to teach math math and literacy it's
no surprise why close to 50 of los
angeles uh that graduate from high
school can't even read or or write or
let alone try to solve any sort of
complex math problem and that it really
stems from the fact that we need to
educate better educators so that when
they move around the united states
they're better equipped at teaching our
children and we need to keep the
standards so that people love children
more than they love politics wouldn't
that be refreshing well going from ron
desantis doing it right here in florida
let's throw to this clip of joe biden
and you're not going to believe who he's
blaming for the culture war we're
talking about
today there are too many politicians
trying to score political points trying
to
ban books
even math books i mean did you ever
think even younger teachers you ever
think when you'd be teaching you're
going to be worrying about book burnings
and banning books
all because it doesn't fit somebody's
political agenda
american teachers
have dedicated their lives to teaching
our children lifting them up
we got to stop making the target of the
culture wars
that's where this is going
so what he's saying there basically is
that any of these uh states that do
anything about critical race theory or
the gender stuff that they're banning
books meaning they're not letting
anti-racist baby and the rest of it in
the curriculum we also don't teach mind
comp i'm pretty sure uh deborah i assume
you don't have a problem and you're
probably a little jealous as a canadian
that some states can do some stuff on
this right
well we're usually about six months
behind you guys so i have that to look
forward to
but i really i really thought this was
like the pot calling the kettle black
and i think this is another way that
this ideology is so insidious because it
makes parents who have understandable
concerns it makes them feel like they're
the crazy ones i mean if you go back to
your earlier example about lunches
i understand why most everyday people
don't want to go up against trans
activists because they are so powerful
and not only are they influencing all
this legal policy and medical and
scientific initiatives but now they're
also getting to say who gets to be fed
in terms of underprivileged kids
that to me has what do bathrooms have to
do with the well-being of children i
mean it's totally crazy to me that if if
you have schools that say they're not in
favor of this ideology you're going to
starve the children
stephen i assume you're against starving
children
i certainly am i'm also against the
federal government being able to hold
the purse strings over education i think
that
it's it's far from obvious to me there's
any constitutional
uh
in the united states there's any
constitutional justification for the
department of education in fact one
thing needs to be said about canada it
doesn't have it does not have a federal
department of education that has led
actually to a greater diversity amongst
the provinces
in what they can do and here in the
united states i think we would do damn
well to return education to the places
that it should be which is uh
fundamentally driven by the parents of
the children and the communities that
serve those children and if we had that
then the federal government wouldn't be
able to coerce us uh of course coerce
their ideology on people by denying
hungry children lunch
yeah and perhaps fund students instead
of systems something that chris ruffo
who i know you guys are all friends with
is really pushing right now